en revanche qu'il faille plus de justice
fiscale mais j'en suis le premier
convaincu qu'il fasait une fiscalité
plus verte et nous sommes tout à fait
prêts à le faire dans le cadre du plan
de relance
mais si vous voulez une fiscalité plus
juste aidez moi monsieur le sénateur je
sais que votre groupe y est prêt à
mettre en place une taxation digitales
non seulement au niveau national mais
aussi au niveau européen vous l'avez
cherché la richesse là où elle se trouve
ce sont les géants du numérique mondiaux
qui ont fait les plus grands profits
pendant cette crise économique c'est eux
qu'il faut les taxer
et c'est cette taxation digital qui sera
juste voulu une taxation verte mais
aidez nous à mettre en place une
taxation carbone aux frontières de
l'union européenne
parce que rien ne sert de décarbonés
notre industrie en france si nous sommes
pas capables de récupérer à l'entrée de
nos frontières
la taxation carbone des produits
importés de l'extérieur
vous voulez une taxation plus juste mais
aidez nous à mettre en place au niveau
européen
la taxation chez transactions
financières qui existent en france mais
qui n'existe pas au niveau européen
étendons cette taxe sur les transactions
financières au niveau européen plutôt
que de le faire au niveau national et
enfin voulait une taxation juste mes
démons à lutter contre l'évasion fiscale
et contre l'optimisation fiscale en
mettant en place une taxation minimale à
l'impôt sur les sociétés
comme nous nous battons pour le faire au
niveau international et que nous
arrivons à le faire avec l'allemagne
vous voyez il ya beaucoup de chantiers à
mettre en oeuvre pour avoir une
fiscalité plus juste au niveau
international comme au niveau national
mais je ne pense pas que ce soit en
renouvelant les erreurs du passé
c'est plutôt en inventant la fiscalité
du futur pour vous répondre
non pas pour vous répondre mais heureux
monsieur savoldelli oui merci monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre je
comprends bien la difficulté qu est la
vôtre
mais enfin reproché aux élus communistes
écologie citoyens de pas est à vos côtés
dans l'évasion fiscale c'est un manque
de sérieux
franchement c'est un manque de sérieux
ça c'est la première chose
la deuxième chose monsieur le ministre
vous et sourire mais l'opinion publique
elle sourit pas on peut pas dire robert
a balayé d'un revers de main il serait
impossible de toucher à 4% les
dividendes
quand on regarde que si dix dernières
années la hausse des dividendes à
augmenter mes chers collègues de 70%
vous connaissez vous quelqu'un un
salarié un paysan vous connaissez
quelqu'un qui ait 70 % d'augmentation
ces dix dernières années donc
franchement c'est pas sérieux
et à chaque fois qu'on vous fait des
propositions que ça soit d'ordre social
ou d'ordre environnemental
on vous pose la question de répartir qui
est un effort fiscal des plus riches
c'est tout le temps non donc ce que vous
êtes en train de faire c'est une
opération de communication avec du
capitalisme vert et là je vous le dis je
vous le dis au gouvernement je pourrais
m'adresser au président de la république
vous êtes sur un populisme il faut
conclure extrêmement dangereux
extrêmement dangereux
[Musique]